it's not a game show it's a sport
you see probably are competing with
their pride on the line yeah ultimate
tag is nothing like the game you played
as a kid NFL superstar bros Derek JJ and
TJ watt host there are five different
courses and each week contestants who
are not professional athletes compete
for ten grand who is the most
competitive of the three of you though
since we're on this competition show to
iron me in case you're wondering all
three bros are buddha TJ has a
girlfriend
Derek is married with a 15 month old son
and JJ just said I do in February to a
pro soccer player and speaking of pros
get this the show has professional
taggers because that's a thing do you
have any tips for me on this game run
fast because we're coming for you don't
get caught we're not going easy okay so
we're getting the body cam on I didn't
realize when I was casually interviewing
you guys that you would be chasing me
beach boy are you waxing or shaving on
the daily or what's your shirt so you
guys are going to try yank this off of
my chest absolutely and you can't try to
guard it either
[Music]
would you guys be scared doing any of
these challenges the dome the dome is
scary it sounds like maybe the whole
family is a little afraid of heights
there is a very large bed yes
Rach that course was scary but I do need
a quarantine workout so I've been
considering setting up ultimate tag in
my home girl I fail you but that workout
is next level Lauren let me know how it
goes okay
[Music]